pauvre idiot aux imbéciles à malappris
nalut rue gougeard jeu trognon vous avez
entendu ma chère à lui il m'a appelé
vieux trognon mois en scène le 19 c'est
inqualifiable
oui mais vous monsieur du snav vous
venez de le traiter de main l'a pris et
de goujat oui et il m'a traité d'un bien
de vieillir diot mois casimir casimir eu
ça ils méritaient bien quand je
l'appelle vieux trop new peut-être pas
après lui avoir dit à abc et malotru je
vous rappelle ma chère amie que nous
étions venu vous chercher votre
arbitrage votre jugement
c'est une à pratiquement rien dit car
depuis que vous êtes arrivé vous ne
cessez de vous insulter
je n'ai pas pu placer un bonbon nous
nous taisons nous vous écoutons voulions
savoir de ce grand bonhomme deux mois
bloqués lesquels le plus à vos gros
balourd et sa maman ouvrage bon le
faisons le moulin sera mis d'accord nous
nous taisons tient alors alors je ne
sais pas où cette occasion quel est le
plus savant d2 mais je vous trouve aussi
bêtes là que l'autre à revoir messieurs
grand vide
4 - l'accord j'ai du travail ça y est ça
marche tout près pareil c'est une
excellente idée d'avoir voulu faire
cette fausse dispute un excellent il ya
une seule chose qui ne m'a pas beaucoup
plus les gros balourd au pardonne moi
quand il n'y a bien que pour ma part
vieux trognon je n'ai pas beaucoup
apprécié au mais je ne le pensais pas
monsieur casamance a à nouveau tout beau
tout est là être tentation doucement il
faut rien reverser bon voilà oui je
crois que bien aussi mes amis j'ai
trouvé le jus de citron et lâchait ce
que vous m'aviez demandé
eh bien je crois que tout est prêt oui
mais vous n'avez pas encore dit la
raison de la surprise que vous préparez
tous les deux à bas cette petite alors
tout alors oui allez prendre votre place
de chanteur attendu pour tout est prêt
le pauvre d'afrique
on l'appelle voilà jus
lee judith julie qui yat il encore
mais qu'est ce que c'est cette une
surprise à sa logique
[Musique]
m
si nous mêmes
10 13
les phobies les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
explique céline
r je voudrais être très sans connaître
le secret des choses y es tu vraiment
quelque part des éléphants et skyteam
deviner ce qu'on trouve au delà des
étoiles il voit ton parfois des lions d
ganley les corbeaux et les blanches tout
arrêt
les canapés
de toul ar gouren les dauphins l'est
marceau qui sont de vrais faits
son
comme des poissons dans la
je voudrais être très sale en connaître
le secret des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants reste quelques un es tu
devines et se trouve au delà des épaules
il voit ton parfois des lions des ans
[Musique]
c'est ce que je voudrais
mais vrai
tous
[Musique]
g
c'est
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
voilà
[Musique]
eh bien c'était une merveilleuse
surprise les gâteaux sont délicieux
chanteur en tout cas vous m'avez bien eu
avec votre dispute fosse est une idée de
casimir une idée excellent fort je vous
remercie monsieur du sinon c'est vrai
kazemi au jeu j'avoue que moi même je
n'ai pas trouvé l'idée satisfaisante
vous faire baisser le rideau de votre
kiosque mon cher ami
en tout cas je préfère vous voir vous
adresser l'un à l'autre avec courtoisie
vous savez notre cher ami que j'ai pour
casimir la plus haute estime malgré les
quelques différends que nous avons quant
à moi je trouve bien sûr du snav
extrêmement sympathique et assez bien
contente
mais dites moi vous n'avez pas donné la
raison de cette bonne surprise mais
c'est vrai ça marchera mieux casimir je
t'en prie je n'en ferai rien mais si
mais si casino boyon et bien voilà cette
petite fête a été organisée pour pour
aller mais j'ai complètement oublié on
écoute que généreuse tombé de mon studio
pour oublier ça ma chère amy je vais
vous le dire
oui nous avons organisé cette petite
fête pour vous
l'action s'est faite rouge j'ai
complètement oublié moi aussi vous
pouviez me traiter d'idiot pouvant
baisser ou rouge entre uma la prie dieu
sogno et austère noyau
auj